all right relationship advice
we're so good at this give it up are we
don't [ __ ] touch me sorry if my
hand's warm bro it's been on my
nuts for about 10 minutes
i thought it smelled like top ramen what
do we got first one's from gen rocks
of texas oh yeah hey guys
ganking buzz buzz jennifer from texas
here
needing some relationship advice
i am single and in my 30s
and i find that i'm having so much
problems in the dating world because i
am a home buddy i am
so completely introverted i
like to stay home and read and watch
movies and work out
i don't know how to put myself out there
because i don't
really thrive in social situations
and so what should i do i've tried the
online dating
no one blows my mind enough to want to
like leave
my little cave and uh i just need your
help
but i gotta go okay my throne's coming
on
gang gang buzz buzz girl and i'm loving
game of thrones game of thrones is
so yesterday but carry on but it's like
figure it out
i agree like just you're on a small
island yeah
just go over just go over one [ __ ]
state popeye how about sending a bird to
somebody that's like hey
take your horse yeah let's drive up the
road let's split a loaf of syphilis and
[ __ ] chat right you know
start having babies create your own
[ __ ] kingdom it's easy get a dragon
shut your [ __ ] mouth
so with this chick though so she doesn't
do well in social environments
good thing is with this day and age with
instagram
tinder grinder bumblebee bumper j
date farmers only you don't have to and
she's like i know i've tried all the
dating
sites i get that listen if you're gonna
fish you want to catch that marlin
you gotta catch some [ __ ] toads
before you catch that marlin you catch
my drift the big old marlin is
out there you just got to keep fishing
girl keep on fishing
and hopefully you don't catch a catfish
you know what i'm saying it's me fishing
i fish for i fish for theo what's up bro
hunting that's all sex that's all dating
is deep sea hunting
but i think you're trying to do too much
at once by making it all happen
but sitting on the apps and just being
judgmental at a certain point it just
doesn't help us i used to do it
and then next thing you know i'd sit
there at night be like yep i just told a
thousand people no
time to mass debate and go to sleep and
that was my life
splitting lettuce wraps by yourself
jericking off into an empty [ __ ]
uh carl's jr box
that double western urinating in a cup
because i'd masturbated so many times i
didn't have enough energy to get to the
bathroom
you've been there bro so it's just a
matter of the future you want to have
right now it's looking pretty sad well
yeah i was jacking off in the [ __ ]
orange julie's
talking about i didn't say that what
else do we got good luck girl
is